pues si en estos momentos están los 12
miembros del jurado de mayoría blanca
reunidos en el edificio donde se ha
estado celebrando a lo largo de estas
tres semanas el juicio ahora tienen que
estar entrados reunidos sin ningún
contacto con el exterior y decidir si el
derecho es inocente o culpable de la
muerte de georg soy un hombre que se ha
convertido en la imagen de la violencia
racial por parte de la policía en eeuu y
en este último día en el último día con
los argumentos finales la acusación ha
dicho que el ex policía actuó de manera
desproporcionada y que george no suponía
ninguna amenaza por su parte la defensa
ha dicho que cuando george frey llegó al
hospital sus niveles de oxígeno estaban
al 98% y volvió a incidir en esa teoría
de que floyd murió a consecuencia de sus
adicciones a las drogas y por sus
problemas de salud
anthony lo decíamos previamente no en
este caso se transformó en todo un
símbolo mundial no sólo en eeuu de la
violencia policial y del racismo
sistémico
sobre el clima social que se ve que se
vive por aquí podemos escuchar de fondo
no sé si hay manifestantes
si de hecho a los pocos minutos de
terminar esta última jornada del juicio
ya se han concentrado algunas personas
en los exteriores de este edificio
gubernamental piden justicia y que haya
un cambio en la normativa de las
actuaciones boe por parte de la policía
en estados unidos consideran que la el
caso de georg se tiene que dar motivos
suficientes para que haya un cambio pero
se esperan disturbios a lo largo de los
próximos días de hecho la guardia
nacional ha desplegado más de 4.000
efectivos por el centro de la ciudad y
las escuelas públicas van a permanecer
cerradas por lo menos desde el miércoles
y hasta el próximo viernes cuando se
ponga a la espera de que pueda haber un
veredicto pero aún no se sabe cuándo va
a ser esa decisión por parte del jugador
principalmente porque tiene que ser una
decisión unánime